this is a great little question that
comes out of an exam and the reason why
I like it is because it's quite simple
to begin with there aren't multiple
parts to or anything like that and yet
its simplicity masks the fact that it
can be approached in many different ways
and some of the ways seem quite
complicated if you do work out what the
best way of solving is it is quite
excuse me elegant and simple and I will
show you that but I'm actually going to
show you three different ways to
approach this question you'll see some
better than others in an exam often we
try and design questions that will have
multiple ways to solve them so that we
are testing to see if students can look
at a ray of strategies and work out
which one not just which one works or
which one is the quickest and the most
efficient okay so the question is find
the equation of this tangent of a
tangent so this function that passes
through a particular point hmm okay so
before we do anything you got to work
out what is this function what does it
look like now some of you might
recognize what the shape is but for
those of you who don't a bit of
manipulation will quickly show you what
it's actually equal to now you've got y
equals the square root of something and
remember the square root it must be
positive okay so you must note that um
at the beginning you've got this range
restriction okay but apart from that
once I note that I can square both sides
and a more familiar shape emerges so if
I square both sides still noting my
restriction okay and rearranged a little
bit so I have my X's over here okay
what's this sorry right that known as a
three squared well this is a circle
right it's Center is at one zero and
it's radius is three ok now this
equation is a circle but I noted this
range restriction so with this
restriction on there and I don't get a
circle out of this I only get the top
half this is a semicircle okay so it
would look like this is the kind of
shape we're talking about okay so
there's the semicircle there's it's um
its center at one zero and because it's
got a um a radius of three it goes up to
from four on this is back over to minus
2 okay now there's six zero in that
point right there okay so this is the
tangent in question I'm trying to work
out what's the equation of of this line
okay so how can I go about this well my
first method is going to be using
calculus okay now this is a it's your
11th exam so people know calculus by now
and if you want to know the equation of
a tangent okay you can define the
equation or any line really any straight
line by a point that it goes through
there's one six zero and the other thing
you need to know is its gradient okay
now to find out gradient that's one of
the things that we often use calculus
for right so if we can work out what the
gradient is right there at that spot
okay because that's where it's tangent
to this semicircle if I can work out the
gradient there that's the gradient of
the whole line and then I'll be able to
say what the equation is okay so how
will I work that out
well for starters let's take this
function right y equals now it's a
square root but I'm going to write it as
a in index form because that'll make it
a little easier for me to say that's
squared for me to differentiate okay if
that is the function what is this
derivative okay so you've got it's a
little awkward but if you're patient
with it it's not too bad so I've got
some chain rule happening here right in
fact I have two instances of chain rule
so I've got this function which is to
the power of 1/2 so what's the
derivative of the inside function and
the derivative the inside function is
well let's have a look you've got minus
X minus 1 all squared okay so I've got a
minus sign at the front so here's my
derivative there's a minus sign now I
bring the power down he comes to you
differentiate the inside just get 1 and
then you reduce the power by 1 okay so
now that's the derivative of the inside
ok now I can start to do the outside
I'll multiply by the power
it's a multiplied by 1/2 and then I'll
reduce the power by 1 now that will make
the power minus 1/2 which means that
negative sign means I'm underneath this
the on the bottom side of the fraction
I'm going to nominator and minus 1/2
well that'll become the square root
again
so that's that just to do a little bit
of tidying you're gonna get lap half out
here he's going to cancel with the two
okay and that's just the one so you're
gonna get minus X plus 1 so 1 minus X
all over the square root of this okay so
there's the derivative of that
semicircle okay now if only I can find
out what the actual X value of this
point is then all I need to do is sub
that value in and then I know the
gradient at this point of the semicircle
and once I know the gradient the tangent
will have the same gradient and off I go
okay so how I gonna go about working
what's this x-coordinate
well if you do a bit of geometry you can
see that there's a well you know from
from the center of the circle up to the
tangent right if I draw this line in
like so because it's a circle property
that the tangent is perpendicular to the
radius at the point of contact okay I
have this right angle here and we
already know that the radius of the
circle is 3 now from here 1 to 6 that's
a distance of 5 units right 5 units
there and because it's a right angle
triangle that means I've got a 3 4 5
triangle okay so 3 4 5 right now
remember what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to work out this x value this
this distance here how am I going to do
it okay the easiest way is probably to
take this sum this altitude here okay if
I stuck a right right angle in there
okay if I can work out some distances in
here for instance if I can work out the
distance from this point here up to
there I can work out that distance then
I can add 1 to that and I'll get this
I'll get this whole distance which is
the x coordinate okay so this is
starting to get there's a lot
information on this diagram so in order
to work out what this distance is I'm
going to redraw just that the triangle
part of the diagram so it's a little
less cluttered for me okay so
is off here okay now what do we have I
think we had this kind of arrangement
okay this side was three this side was
four
this whole side was five but rather than
right in five at the moment I'm gonna
draw in the altitude like so and
remember this is what I'm trying to find
this distance in here okay so I'm going
to call that capital X now since the
whole distance we the base we said was
five that makes this section here five
minus X okay and one more label here
I'll call this Y I suppose Capital y
because the second it's a vertical just
since won't matter what it is anyway cuz
I'm gonna sub it out in a second now
let's remember that because I am this is
an altitude I've got a right angle here
I've also got a right angle here okay so
I've got to write angular triangles and
they're related to each other okay let's
have a look at this triangle here on the
Left I can say that x squared plus y
squared is equal to nine by Pythagoras
okay so if I rearrange that I'm gonna
make Y squared the subject cuz I'm gonna
get rid of it later on so I'm just gonna
stir that value that result away for a
second I was a left-hand triangle now
have a look at this triangle the sides
are a little more complicated but
they're not that bad this is five minus
x squared down here Plus this shorter
side again squared that should be equal
to 16 because that's this where the
hypotenuse okay so now I can substitute
this Y squared for nine minus x squared
okay so I've got five minus X or squared
plus 9 minus x squared that's 16 okay
and now you can see this is not gonna be
too hard I just need to tidy up a little
bit so let's expand this guy that gives
me 25 minus 10 X plus x squared I'll
kick that 9 over which is going to make
a 7 over here and that's minus x squared
see these these cancel okay bring the 25
over so that gives me minus 18 so X is
equal to I can take out a factor of 2
and they get 9 over 5 okay all right now
bring that back over to this diagram so
that tells me this distance in here the
red distance is 9
over five okay which means that the
ex-con I'm after is on one plus nine and
five because you can see I go one and
then I go nine and five that distance
okay so the x value I'm after this this
coordinate of this point is 1 plus 9
over 5 which is let's see Q
well actually I'm gonna I'm gonna leave
that because when I think about the
derivative it's going to actually be
useful to me to have that 1 plus because
I'm gonna have some some subtraction in
a second so let's just keep that now
heads up the x value that I want
remember that the derivative do you want
any X is equal to 1 minus X all over the
square root of 9 minus X minus 1 all
squared ok so when I've got this
particular value 1 plus known over 5
what's going to happen well on the top
I'm going to have 1 minus 1 minus that
okay so the ones will cancel and I'll
just be left with beef minus 9 over 5
okay fractions on fractions so just
watch out Chuck some brackets in there
then what do I have on the denominator
I've got 9 - now I've got X minus 1 all
squared right and that's X so when I
take away 1 I just get left with the 9
fifths 9 fifths and that's a squared ok
so let's see I've got minus 9 over 5 up
on the top there and this I worked out
earlier actually is going to end up
being 144 over 25 okay so so far so good
and this is going to be equal to it
minus 9 over 5 on now that's a square
and that's a square that's 12 squared
and that's 5 squared so it'll be 12 on 5
the fives will cancel so you get minus
3/4 okay now that's actually the
gradient that I mopped up the gradient
of the tangent okay so I can say the
tangent will have an equation and
remembering that what I've got is a
gradient and a point so I'll use a point
gradient form which looks like this okay
so let's see here what were the
coordinates I think it was six zero
wasn't it at Y minus zero this will be X
minus six and here's my gradient in
there minus 3/4 ok so now when you
multiply out if you just put that in a
in a general form you're gonna get
multiply the four across you've got
minus three X plus 18 so we'll just tidy
that up and there's your answer
okay so that was method one which was
calculus okay because you needed to
differentiate and because you were
substituting in a value of x at the
dreary so you get a specific gradient
that's why we had to muck around with
those triangles okay there's the first
solution now there's another way of
doing this in some ways you might you
might call it a clever way though it'll
end up being you'll still take quite a
while of working we get a new color here
and that is to use the discriminant okay
now what's the discriminant the
discriminant is when you've got a uhm
when you've got a quadratic of any kind
okay the discriminant is b squared minus
4ac and the reason it's important is
because when you look at the quadratic
formula for a quadratic b squared minus
4ac is what's underneath the square root
right when you're solving solving this
guy you'll get minus b plus or minus the
square root of b squared minus 4ac all
over 2a so you can see here that the
value that discrim is very important if
the discriminative then this thing will
have no real solutions because you're
taking the square root of a negative
number okay if the screen is positive
you'll get two roots most significantly
if the discriminant is 0 that means
there will be you know when you think
about the roots of this will be minus B
plus or minus the square root of 0 so
that's minus B plus or minus 0 so you
just get minus me on to a there's just
one solution when you have a
discriminant of 0 that's really
important ok so we're gonna use that
fact in a second you just have to
get away you remember what I want to do
is think about the fact that okay when I
solve these two equations separately the
equation of this semicircle and the
equation of this tangent okay then I
should be able to find one and only one
solution right so that's where the
discriminant is going to come in so what
are the two equations I'm trying to
solve
you've got the semicircle which is R
this guy okay and then you've got the
tangent now you can see even without
having done the previous question that
the tangent is going to be in this form
right and I don't know what the the
gradient is yet at least because I
restarted this question but I do know
the points that it goes through which is
six zero so I can know that the equation
of the tangent is at least in this form
and all I have to do is find the
gradient which is what we're doing last
time with the derivative okay
now therefore if I want to solve these
simultaneously okay I'm just gonna say
look let's take this okay and solve it
simultaneously with this okay now we're
gonna we gonna run into some problems in
a second because I'm gonna square
everything okay
but we'll resolve that later okay square
everything adds another solution so
later on we're gonna have to remove one
okay so I'm gonna try and solve this
well at least at least rearrange it so I
can find the discriminant out of there
okay so what's gonna happen was just
square both sides here I don't forget to
square both parts of the product okay
now if you expand everything what are we
going to get 9 minus let's see here okay
x squared minus 2x plus 1 okay this is a
little awkward but it'll be M squared X
plus 6
okay now what I want to do is get
everything all together okay so if I
expand out first I'm gonna get 8 minus x
squared plus 2x from the 9 and the 1
okay and then if I expand this out M
squared x squared 12 and other m's
red X and then 36 M squared okay now my
goal is to get it into this form okay
because then I'll see what a and B and C
are and then I can work out my
discriminant okay so if I put this into
general form let's get all the X
Squared's together how many are there
there's M squared X Squared's here
that's a computing is M Squared lots and
there's when I bring this over there we
one lot right so there will be M squared
plus one
lots of x squared when I put them all
together how many boxes of X are they
gonna be there's going to be this many
how many X's and then your constant term
will be and I'll put in brackets just to
make it clearer that's going to be your
constant term okay okay so I've just
gotten the this awkward long equation
into general form okay now don't forget
what this equation is what it represents
is because where I started which was
here right which is the points of
intersection once you solve this you're
solving them simultaneously you get
where these two things intersect now the
whole point of me doing this is because
I know because it's a tangent this is
this is what it looks like yeah I know
there should be only one point of
intersection okay so that's really
useful to me now having having got that
put it into this awkward form so that I
can see that bits that's a that's B and
that's C okay so out of that I can now
work out the discriminant and the
discount is B squared B squared sorry B
squared minus 4a that's a C okay now
this looks really terrible okay but a
lot of stuff's going to factorize out
for instance if you have a look here
you've got a factor of minus 2 in here
right so if I do some bigger brackets
you take our minus 2 out that's going to
give you 6m squared plus 1 okay and
that's all squared and the reason why
that minus 2 squared is useful is
because there's a 4 there so they're
both fours okay so they're going to
cancel on a second once I write all of
this out and so our numbers will be not
quite as awkward as they were going to
be so that's gonna become 4 so I'll just
get rid of that
just leave him off squared plus one that
four is going to go the reason why by
the way I can I can get rid of it it's
because I'm saying that it's cream is
equal to zero
right so I'm dividing both sides by 4
minus this okay
and so now even this looks terrible
especially in fact you've got an M
Squared squared here and an M Squared
squared here again things are going to
go nice and neatly because for instance
have a look what happens here that 6m
squared or squared becomes 36 M to the 4
then you double that and then you get a
1 on the end right then what happens
here you're going to subtract now if we
want to expand this out you're going to
get another 36 m to the 4 there right
then minus 8 M Squared that's the first
2 then plus 36 M squared minus 8 okay so
that's going to cancel with that it's
still a bit of tidying up it's over the
squared plus 1 - okay - 8 plus 36
what's that that's 24 right wait hold on
28 - 28
minus 8 okay so 12 minus 28 that's going
to be minus 16 M squared plus 1 minus
minus 8 so that's plus 9 it's always
equal to 0 so now what if I got take
that minus 9 over the other side this is
starting to look familiar because you
actually already know from the first way
we solved that what the value of M is
right so M Squared is 9 on 16 so now
here at this point if this is the first
way you solved it right you can't expect
you can't just exclude an answer and say
you think I know which one it's going to
be you have to include both and then
provide the justification for why you're
excluding 1 ok so I think probably the
easiest way is to say well look from
this diagram being we've got the top
half the semicircle here the liner we've
got is clearly decreasing right so its
gradient its gradient has to be less
than zero ok so I would say that on the
basis of the diagram
that's sufficient supposing your tiger
is actually half-decent from the diagram
okay therefore you can exclude the
positive answer and you get this only
and that brings you back to because we
already had we already had the equation
of the line and then it goes just the
same from there so what did you get
we've got 3x plus 4y minus 18 don't okay
now that was the second solution which
is for the discriminant that was still
really long and awful though and there
was lots of little opportunities for the
algebra to go badly not to mess the
algebra algebra really just is the
arithmetic which even even I myself made
a mistake so is there a better way the
answer is yes now come back to this
original diagram okay there's something
hiding in here that is is gonna be super
super quick to work out the answer and
actually is introduced all the way back
when you first do right angle triangle
trick which would be either you know no
your turn depending on which stage
firestream you're doing and have a look
at this triangle here okay this one yeah
which is as we know that it's
right-angled because the tangent is
perpendicular to the radius okay and
because it's right-angled and I know
what all the sides are equal to right
that tells me a lot about the angles of
the triangle in particular for instance
look at that angle in the corner call
that feet up okay now because the 345
triangle right I can say on the basis of
this that tan theta is equal to opposite
on adjacent which is 3/4 okay now that
seems a bit sort of plucked out the blue
why would I I want to say you know 10
feet oh well because remember the whole
what makes this problem hard why we
introduced calculus and why we had to
muck around with the discriminator is
because I'm trying to work out what the
gradient of this line is right that's
the hard part that's the only real thing
you need to work out because I know I'm
already going through this point and of
course if you remember gradient is
connected to 10 right because 10 is
about opposite adjacent
rise over run if you draw the
appropriate triangles right now in this
case you can see that M is not 3/4
because like you said is decreasing
right so I can say from the diagram on
the basis of the fact that 10 theta is
equal to 3/4 M has to be minus 3/4
I can say it simply on the basis of the
fact that tan Peter is 3/4 that's it I
don't have to fuss around with the
derivative or anything like that and I
already know it's in the form y equals M
outside of X minus 6 so you simply have
to substitute that in and then rearrange
everything into general form just like
we did before and there's your answer in
I don't know less than 30 seconds
however long it took to get that ok
so classic example of where there's lots
of different approaches to a question
and what's really being tested is not
just your understanding of current
geometry but whether you can work out
what's the fastest most efficient way
because otherwise it would cost you for
the rest of the exam even if you get it
right but the long way around